[MUSIC PLAYING]
In '72, Millie became
the associate department
head in EECS and before
then and since then
has had a very illustrious
career in research and science.
At one time, Millie, I
guess about 10 years ago,
was president of the
American Physical Society.
She's an institute professor
and has appointments
in both the
department of physics
and the department of
electrical engineering.
She won the National
Medal of Science
back in 1990, probably
the highest award
that the country US can give
to one of its scientists.
She's the recipient of
over 17 honorary degrees.
Recently in 1999, she
received an honorary degree
from the Sorbonne in Paris.
And it turned out that
she's the first woman
to have received an honorary
degree in the sciences
from the Sorbonne.
In this year, just last week,
she received an honorary degree
from the University
of Leuven in Belgium
and next week will be giving
the [? Celsius ?] lectures
at the University of
Uppsala in Sweden.
As I say, Millie has a very
illustrious and long list
of honors.
And if I went
through all of them,
I'd take up half of her time.
I think you really want
to hear from Millie.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm very honored to
be the first one.
Again, I did the first in
the EECS series about a year
or a year and a half ago.
And so it's auspicious
beginning, as we all say.
My topic today is very
different from last time.
This time, I'm talking
about bismuth nanowires.
And I could give almost
the same topic title
as I gave last time,
which was The Remarkable
Structure of Properties
of Carbon Nanotubes.
That's the last one I did
in the EECS Colloquium.
But I was a little
bit more modest
because the bismuth
nanowires are a lot newer
and maybe we don't know exactly
all the remarkable properties
about them yet.
Well, I have a
few collaborators,
actually worldwide, and a
lot of graduate students.
And three of them have
already gotten their PhDs
related to this topic, so a good
subject for training students.
Now, in light of
the invitation, I
thought I would focus my remarks
about nanostructures before I
start talking about bismuth.
Those of you who listened to the
president's State of the Union
speech, he didn't have a lot to
say about science, but he did
have something to say
about nanostructures.
And so nanowires are a
part of nanostructures.
So I'd like to
call your attention
to the importance of this.
And in my first
viewgraph, I'm trying
to give you the scale of
what a nanostructure is.
And so here we have a
plot, and we have a plot
of different things on a scale.
So you see that the
x-axis here gives size.
And there's a line here.
That's at about 50, 70
nanometers, something
like that.
And anything below that begins
to show quantum effects.
And with quantum
effects, it's not
that we're just making
things smaller and smaller
to get a higher packing
ratio of whatever component
it is like we're doing
silicon technology.
The first thought is to pack
our devices smaller and smaller
so you get a higher
packing density.
But when you do
this, you also get
new physics that comes in that
allows you to do new things.
And it's the second
point of view
that I'd like to stress
in my talk today.
So you see here on
this picture, there
are a lot of different things--
GMR, Giant Magneto Resistance;
quantum dots and lasers;
nanotubes, carbon
nanotubes, which
I talked about in my last
EECS Colloquium, et cetera.
And bismuth nanowires
span the scale
moving into the
nanostructure regime
where quantum effects
are important.
My second viewgraph of a general
nature about nanostructures
tells you in simple
terms why nanostructures
are important and interesting,
why anybody cares about them,
why President Clinton said
that this is something
that we should be thinking
about and working on.
Why is that?
Well, when we have bulk
semiconductors as we know
and we love in the industry,
what we basically have is this
situation shown on top where
the density of states--
that is the number of
states per energy range--
is essentially continuous.
That is, we have a
crystal structure
that's really quite large
compared to the quantum regime
limit.
On the other end of the
scale here, quantum dot,
labelled quantum dot, where
we might have a single atom
or molecule, we have
discrete states.
And somewhere in between, we
have one-dimensional systems.
Like here, we have
the quantum wire.
Or in this case, we
have the quantum well,
which is a
two-dimensional system.
And you will see that
the density of states--
that is the number of
states per energy range--
is distinctly different.
And the smaller the size
or the smaller dimension
that we're dealing with,
the more the system
becomes like a molecule
with these discrete states.
Now, when we are in the
regime of the discrete states,
we have new phenomenon.
And that's the kind
of thing that I'm
going to emphasize
in my discussion
of the bismuth
nanowires where we're
interested in going to
smaller and smaller sizes
where the system shows quantum
effects, that phenomenon that
are not present in the bulk.
Now I'd like to tell you how I
got into the bismuth nanowire
business.
And this was motivated by
practical considerations.
One of the nice things about
being in an engineering
department is we have a push
and pull between the practical
and the science-based studies.
So my initial
motivation for this
came from a practical
driver, and this
is interest in making
thermoelectrics that are better
than present thermoelectrics.
Thermoelectrics have
two applications.
One is for cooling
purposes, and the other
is for energy conversion
at high temperature.
And here is a picture diagram
of the thermoelectric figure
of merit.
For our present discussion, this
isn't particularly important
except to say that the
state-of-the-art has a value
of this quantity,
figure of merit, ZT,
dimensionless quantity, of 1.
And it's been at this value
since approximately 1960.
If thermoelectrics could have
their figure of merit increased
to a factor of 3, they could be
competitive to a refrigerator,
something that we know.
And it would change the
economics and interest
in this kind of applications
area enormously.
However, nobody
has figured out how
to do this, and not for lack
of effort but lack of ideas.
We had an idea about how to
change this a few years ago
by going to low dimensions.
And you could see this picture
is sort of a visionary picture.
And it said if you could make
a one-dimensional bismuth,
or two-dimensional,
for that matter,
we could exceed the ZT of 1
with small sizes of either
a quantum well of bismuth
or a quantum wire of bismuth
and in fact get values that are
phenomenally bigger than even
what you could do
with a refrigerator.
However, there's a long way
to go from the actuality
and this phantom dream.
The material, the actual
material that might do this
would be this bismuth
that I mentioned,
which has some
astounding properties.
Of all materials, it has a
constant energy surface--
we call this a Fermi surface--
that is more anisotropic
than any other material.
Anisotropy in the Fermi
surface is very, very desirable
for thermoelectricity, as is
multiple carrier pockets, which
is another feature of bismuth.
Bismuth also has a
very high mobility,
which is another promising
feature for thermoelectrics.
And because it is
a very heavy atom,
it has a very low
thermal conductivity.
And for all of
these reasons, this
should be the ideal material
to be used for thermoelectric.
However, the
problem with bismuth
and the reason why
bismuth has never
succeeded as a
thermoelectric has
to do with the following
point, property.
Bismuth is a semimetal with
an equal number of electrons
and holes so that the top of
the valance span, shown here,
is higher in energy than the
bottom of the conduction band.
So it's sort of a semiconductor
with a negative bandgap.
So you always have both
electrons and holes present.
And for thermoelectricity, the
contribution of the electrons
essentially cancels
that of the holes,
and it is a very poor
thermoelectric material
for that reason.
However, if you could figure out
some way to make this material
either totally n-type
or totally p-type--
and for thermoelectric, you
have to be able to do both--
then this could be
very, very interesting.
So here is the idea.
And this is an idea that we
had simultaneously almost
with the idea of
doing low-dimensional
thermoelectrics.
What I have shown
on this picture
here is the subband structure
or the first subband
for electrons related to
the band edge for the bulk
and the first subband
which is below the bandgap
edge for the holes, as shown
on your left-hand side.
So now, as the size of the
quantum well or the quantum
wire decreases, the
difference in energy
between the first subband
and the band edge increases.
So this subband
edge will move up.
And for the holes, this
subband edge will move down.
And eventually at some value
of the size of your quantum
well or your quantum wire, a
semiconductor will be formed.
And once you have
a semiconductor,
you could make that
either n or p-type.
So that was the
initial motivation
of us studying bismuth.
And we talked somebody
into giving us
some money to do this.
So we started work
on this project.
But an idea was
necessary because it
isn't easy to make any
low-dimensional structures
with bismuth because
bismuth diffuses
into almost everything.
So we had to devise
some mechanism
to have quantum-confined system.
And the idea came through
a public service activity
for Jackie Ying, who's a
collaborator on this project.
And she invited me to
tell chemical engineers
about carbon nanotubes.
And while they were
listening to me tell them
about carbon
nanotubes, I thought
I should listen to them
tell me about catalysis.
So I listened to a
lecture and heard
about molecular sieves and my
cells that will self-orient.
This is used in the
oil recovery business.
They have, of
course, no interest
in making low-dimensional
semiconductors.
But in listening to
them, I had the idea
what they do is make
self-organized holes
in a template.
So they make something
that looks like this.
And when I saw this,
I said, viola, this
is exactly what we need for
low-dimensional thermoelectrics
and many other
scientific applications.
So we start out here
with an aluminum film.
And so that's like
aluminum foil.
It's a little bit
maybe higher purity
and we polish the
surface, et cetera,
anodize this electrochemically.
And there's a
competing mechanism
that forms these holes.
And depending on
the acid that's used
for the electrochemical
treatment, the length of time,
the voltage, current
conditions, you
can control the size of
the pores, et cetera.
So these pores are made.
And then we use another
acid to take off
the bottom and high pressure
to fill the channels that are
formed eventually with fluids--
in this case, bismuth, but you
can put in magnetic fluids,
something goes superconducting,
many, many possibilities.
And for some applications,
we would like
to measure individual wires.
So we dissolve this template.
We have individual wires to
make for probe measurements
on individual wires.
That's where Hank
Smith's help has come in.
So Jackie Ying taught us
how to make these templates
and helped us with the
filling of the templates.
And we had a lot of help
from Professor Smith
with his kind introduction.
But he's done more than that.
He's helped us to make
transport measurements.
Our earliest work was done.
This is our first attempt.
And you see here, first student.
So these wires are a little
bit on the large side,
65 nanometers, just
at the junction
of being called nanostructures.
And so looking down top-on,
you could see these cylinders.
They're not so perfect, but
the length-to-diameter ratio is
about 1,000--
1,000 aspect.
So they're long, skinny things.
And the density of wires
here was approximately 10
to the 10th wires per
square centimeters.
We do more than that
with the smaller wires.
So there were a lot of
wires that are made.
And I'd like to show Yumeng's
more recent work with improved
processing step.
And this is a much
smaller diameter wire.
And they're more perfect
than the large ones
that the previous student made.
And now we're down
to 18 nanometers,
and these aren't so bad.
We have ideas for
improving them further.
So the technology is
challenging to us,
but our electrical
engineering students
seem to be able to handle this
and make progress with it.
When we take the templates,
dissolve the templates,
you see here the
freestanding wires.
They're very long and skinny.
And with
high-resolution TEM, you
could see that they're
fairly straight.
And these striations show grain
boundary structures, not very
many grain boundaries but
some grain boundaries.
And the size of these
grain boundaries
is about the diameter
of the tubes.
So this is something that
we're very interested in.
Now, the nanowires would
be of relatively little use
were it not for this great
property that they have,
that the nanowires are single
crystals with common axis
along the wires.
So a given wire will
have a common axis,
but all the wires in the array,
the 10 to the 10th or so wires,
will have the same common
axis, most of them,
a high percentage.
And you could see this as
the X-ray diffraction pattern
with very sharp lines so it
looks like a single crystal.
Now, what we found
recently-- in our first work,
we were making
bigger sized wires.
And all the wires had
the orientation 101.
And we thought that they'd
all came out that way.
But as the wire
diameters got smaller,
we have a new preferred
orientation that
goes from 40 down to about 20.
And we haven't really
done much characterization
below that length, but we
suspect that they're also
single crystals.
So this is an
important property.
Why is it important?
All the wires are the same so
they have a common property.
So we can characterize them.
And because of this, we're
able to have very long mean
free paths.
We have a property that's called
ballistic transport that I'll
describe in a little bit that
says that the electrons will
move for very long distances
before being scattered,
for distances that are much
longer than the wire diameters.
So that's an important
consideration.
Another thing that I should
mention about this that makes
this property quite remarkable
is that the crystal structure--
that is, these
diffraction peaks--
are exactly at the same
places, same angles as they
are in bulk bismuth.
So we have basically bulk
bismuth that's put in the wire.
So almost everything that we
know about bulk bismuth also
applies to the nanowires.
This was an unexpected, lovely
property for these nanowires.
Now, other people have tried
to make nanowires before
of this sort, but this was
the first successful attempt
of making single-crystal
nanowires, certainly
of bismuth.
Now, how do we know that
they're all the same?
Well, we have an X-ray
diffraction pattern
which gives you the
of many, many nanowires.
And then we have an
electron diffraction pattern
for single, selected nanowires.
And so from this
pattern, we can tell what
the orientation happens to be.
And that orientation is the same
as for the X-ray diffraction.
So we know that not only
do we have single crystals,
but they're all the same,
close to all the same.
Obviously there's
some deviation.
You never have perfection
in a project like this.
The Raman spectra
is also interesting.
And I show, on top, the Raman
spectra for bulk bismuth.
And because it's
such a heavy atom,
the vibrational modes are
at very low frequency.
And when we make the
nanowires, you'll
see that the same
frequencies appear.
So we have the same
mode structure,
but the relative
intensities are different.
And this is an area
that we hope to be
studying in the near future.
So to summarize about
the remarkable structure
of the nanowires--
so here's the
structural properties.
We have narrow distribution of
wire diameters, less than 10%.
They're quite uniform
along the length-- again,
much less than 10%.
They're single crystals with
a common axis along the wire
but otherwise randomly oriented
in the cross-sectional area
with respect to each other,
not with respect to each one
but with respect to each other.
And they have the same crystal
structure as bulk bismuth.
The template material in which
the bismuth nanowires sit
is a wide-gap semiconductor,
3 and 1/2 electron volts.
So we have quantum-confined
electrons in the wires.
They don't talk to each other.
And thermal conductivity
is very low,
and a bunch of other
interesting properties--
dielectric constants very
high, a few other interesting
properties.
Now I'm going to talk about
the unusual properties.
Up until now, we talked
about the structure.
Now I'm going to talk
about the properties.
So the first thing was the
semimetal-semiconductor
transition.
And just to remind
you what that is--
I hope I can find my little
viewgraph that showed that.
Here we go.
So this is the basic viewgraph.
What we're looking
at, we're looking
for that diameter
for the wire where
this subband for the
holes crosses the highest
electron subband
for the electrons
and a band gap is formed.
So that's the concept of
what we're looking for.
And now I'd like to give a few
examples of its observation.
So we have optical properties,
transport properties,
and several other properties.
So now to get a little
bit more specific
about the bismuth structure,
I have to show you--
bismuth is a
complicated material.
And if it weren't
complicated, most
of the things I'm talking
about would not happen.
So we have the L-point electron.
So these are the
L-point electrons.
And there are multiple
carrier pockets
which will have the same
energy in the bulk material.
But once we make
nanowires out of them,
then we have a splitting
in energy between them,
and that complicates our
thinking about the problem.
But for this audience
and the simple picture,
we'll neglect that
for the most part.
And here are the holes.
And if we didn't have the
rhombohedral crystal symmetry
and this were cubic, the
T-point holes and the T
and L point would
be all the same,
and we wouldn't have a semimetal
so that the special properties
of bismuth that allow us to
make a semiconductor out of it
by going to low
dimensions are bound up,
are closely connected
with the fact
that bismuth is anisotropic.
OK, so this is an
important consideration.
I'll return to
this at some point.
And now, just, I'd
like to mention
about the
semimetal-semiconductor
transition.
So here's our picture for
the semimetal-semiconductor
transition.
At large values of
the wire diameter,
then the separation that
we're talking about here
would be a band
overlap of bismuth,
which is about 40 millivolts.
What's shown here, for the
direction that the wires
actually grow, we have
the A-point pockets
that are along this
cross-section, which
is the mirror plane of the
reciprocal lattice zone,
this carrier pocket is
different from the B and C.
The details of that
are not terribly
important for our
present discussion.
In the limit that the
wires are very large,
then these two lines
become equal to each other
and we have a common value
for this band overlap.
As the wire dimension gets
smaller, we get a splitting.
And this shows the splitting
that makes the A and B and C
different.
And the reason
for that has to do
with the relation of the
symmetry of these carrier
pockets and the
growth direction which
are not along a common
high-symmetry axis.
The important point is that
as the diameter gets smaller,
eventually we get a crossover
with this whole band level.
This is the highest conduction
subband for the holes.
And at this point, we cross
this A-point carrier pocket.
the B and C carrier pocket.
And at this point right
here, 50 nanometers,
we make the
semimetal-semiconductor
transition.
So that's what
we're talking about.
And what is the
evidence that we have
for observing this phenomenon?
[INAUDIBLE] where's the
Fermi energy [INAUDIBLE]
Well, the Fermi energy will
be somewhere between these two
such that the
number of electrons
is equal to the
number of holes, OK?
[INAUDIBLE]
Hm?
It goes right through here
if you have [INAUDIBLE]..
So how would this be observed?
Now, the most prosaic
and simple observation
is to do an optical
absorption experiment.
So if you have a
semiconductor, then you
have a transparent situation,
very low absorption.
And if you have a
semimetal, you'll
have relatively high absorption,
and that's what's shown here.
So this is a very crude,
simple-minded picture
of what you might see.
And so this is the
first experiment we did.
So that's like a
flashlight-type experiment.
And we're trying now to do
this much more quantitatively.
And that's the thesis
of Marcie Black.
And she's making good
progress with it.
So hopefully, soon
we'll hear more details.
The transport properties
are quite interesting.
So here is bulk bismuth.
So this is resistance normalized
to the room temperature value.
And I'll explain
in a little while
why we have to do it that way.
So this is bulk bismuth.
And you see when we
get to the nanowires,
the temperature dependence
of the resistance
is very, very different
from bulk bismuth.
And in fact, these
wires down here
are the semimetallic wires while
those wires up there are all
semiconducting.
And you could see that
the behavior is very, very
different.
And what determines
temperature-dependent
resistance is
always an interplay
between the
temperature dependence
of the carrier density,
which for a semiconductor
is very strong.
And the second
effect, of course,
is the temperature dependence
of a mobility, which
is more important for
the semimetallic phase
so that the interplay between
these and the fact also
that the semi-conducting,
semimetal properties are also
temperature-dependent
is what's responsible
for this complex behavior.
So these are the experiments
done for a number of nanowires.
And this is Yumeng's
recent calculation
for his master's thesis.
And here's 70-- no
adjustable parameters here.
Here is 70 nanometers,
and here is 70 nanometers
for the experiment.
That looks pretty good.
And the 36 is shown there.
So this much we are
able now to explain
with a simple calculation.
And I'll get to that in a
moment, what we do about that.
But there are still
details to be filled in.
We don't have all
the answers yet,
but this is what we've
accomplished thus far.
At low temperatures,
very low temperatures
where localization effects are
beginning to become important--
below 10 degrees,
localization effects
become important, like
in the 2 degree range.
That you see here more clearly
that for the semiconducting
tubes, the coefficient of
resistance with temperature
is positive for the
semimetal phase going up.
And for the conducting
phase, it's going down.
And there are no
exceptions for that.
The situation for
the magnetoresistance
is quite interesting
also but more complicated
for an explanation, so I
didn't bring that along.
But it fits in with the general
picture that I've told you.
This viewgraph shows the
more complicated situation
which underlines the temperature
dependence of the properties
of the bismuth nanowires.
So if we have a
very small nanowire,
like a 10-nanometer diameter
nanowire, then all the way
from the lowest temperature all
the way to room temperature,
it behaves like a semiconductor.
And then you see, for
many orders of magnitude,
the carrier density
is going to change.
This is a plot of
carrier density
with an exponential scale as
a function of temperature.
On the other hand, if we
have an 80-nanometer wire,
then it's always semimetallic
independent of temperature
for this entire range.
And you see that the dependence
of that carrier density
in that case is very minor.
So this shows you about the
interplay between the carrier
density for the different kinds
of nanowires, temperature,
and resistivity
transport properties.
Now, for an intermediate
case, 40 nanometers
at low temperatures behaves
like a semiconductor,
at high temperature
behaves like a semimetal.
So this wire undergoes a
semiconductor-semimetal
transition as a
function of temperature.
And that is part
of the explanation
that we showed you for
the temperature-dependent
transport.
Now, the next phenomenon
that I'd like to talk about
is ballistic transport
in these materials.
What is ballistic transport?
This phenomenon occurs when
the mean free path is large
compared to the
size of the sample.
And when that happens, you can
have wave propagation instead
of particle propagation.
Now, in our case, we
use a magnetic field
to demonstrate this phenomenon.
And I'll show you
how we do that.
So the next viewgraph shows how
we do transport measurements
on our nanowire arrays.
And after, I'll show you how
we do it on a single nanowire.
So here we have
many, many nanowires.
We have 10 to the
10th nanowires.
They were all lined up,
and we put electrode
on the top and the bottom.
And we could measure
either resistance,
or we could measure
magnetoresistance,
resistance in the presence
of a magnetic field.
We do both of those
kinds of experiments.
And they give us a
lot of information.
The information we cannot
get from this is what is
the absolute value of the
resistance as a function
of temperature.
And the reason for
that is we don't
know how many nanowires we have
in our sample that are actually
contacting the electrodes.
And we have no way of measuring
that at the present time.
So we have to do normalized
measurements when
we're working in this format.
The other problem, is that we
have some contact resistance
so that two-point
measurements never
give you very accurate
absolute measurements.
However, these kinds
of measurements
are fine for looking
for phenomenon
like ballistic transport.
So this viewgraph demonstrates
ballistic transport
in some way.
So for example, the black
curve is taken at 100 Kelvin.
And you just see an
increasing function
of the resistance as a
function of magnetic field.
However, when we get down
to lower temperatures,
you see that there's a peak.
There's a maximum.
The maximum has to do
with the following effect.
At low magnetic
fields, the electrons
are making large orbits.
So they tend to bump
into the edge of the wire
more frequently than
they would normally
because the magnetic field
deflects magnetic fields
along the wire
direction, magnetic field
deflects the path
of the electrons
so they intersect with
the edge more frequently.
And therefore, they
have more scattering.
And therefore, the
resistance goes up.
However, when the magnetic
field gets large enough
to start containing
the electrons to move
within the wire
diameter, then we
have less scattering
than we had before.
And therefore, the
resistance goes down.
Well, that's a hypothesis.
And now I'll show you all
the different parameters
that we try is in agreement
with that hypothesis.
I'll show you a few
of them, but we've
done quite a number
of others besides what
I'm showing you here.
Here is the comparison
for two diameters.
So if you have a
smaller diameter,
it takes a larger magnetic field
to have the orbit contained
within the wire diameter.
So for the smaller
diameters, the critical field
is higher than for the larger
diameters, as is shown here.
And the dependence
actually goes like, 1,
over the diameter in
the inverse diameter.
And we have a nice plot of that.
So the picture of what's going
on is shown in this viewgraph.
So for zero field, of course
you have some scattering.
But as the field
increases a little bit,
the orbits are deflected so
that there's increased contact
with the wire.
So the resistance goes up.
But then when the high
magnetic fields are reached
and we get these
circular orbits,
then [? we tend to ?] start
missing the interaction
with the boundaries.
And we can see this
ballistic transport effect.
So now, if the magnetic field
instead of being along the wire
is transverse to the
wire, we should not
see this effect at all.
So OK, here we are at transverse
magnetic field independent
of temperature.
They're all
approximately quadratic.
And with the
longitudinal field if you
add some dopants
so that you make
the mean free path
of the electrons--
the electrons never
reach the wire boundary.
They don't know the
wire boundary is there.
So then it behaves
again quadratically.
Another very interesting
phenomenon that occurs
has to do with orbits
in a magnetic field
at low temperatures.
In our solid state course, we
talk about the magnetic length
of electrons.
So electrons in a magnetic field
experience the quantization
of the magnetic energy levels.
And the magnetic length is
given here by this relation.
And this is a measure of
the size of an electron wave
function in a magnetic field.
When the wire diameter
and the magnetic length
become approximately
equal to each other
so that the magnetic
lengths are shown here
for the various wires, as shown
on this picture, magnetic field
corresponding to these
lengths, and when
that length is equal to the wire
diameter, we have these lines.
And you will see on these
curves that there are kinks.
On the lowest one on
the top, 70 nanometers,
you see quite a large kink.
And for fields lower than
that point where that--
well, I should say
that the kink occurs
when one flux unit is
contained within the wire,
one quantum flux
unit of magnetic flux
is contained within the wire
diameter, there is an effect.
Below that effect, we have
confinement because of the wire
diameter.
So that's a
one-dimensional effect.
And for higher
magnetic fields, we
have confinement because
of the magnetic field.
So the diameter, the size
of the wire, dimensionality
of the wire, is not important.
So we have a changeover
in effect in phenomenon
and therefore,
different dependencies
of the resistance on
magnetic field temperature
and everything else.
One of the drawbacks of
our measurement technique
is that we don't know how many
wires we make contact with.
So we have to do some kind of
measurement on single wires.
And Hank has helped us
with his liftoff technique
to allow us to make contacts
with individual wires.
So here is an individual wire.
And there were a lot of
processing steps that you see.
We have a grid that's defined
photolithography, actually,
by an electron beam.
So we have a lot of points here.
And we use these points to
locate where a given wire is.
So here is a given wire.
And the wire position relative
to some [INAUDIBLE] marks
is noted.
And then we apply
photolithographic techniques
to attach leads to this wire.
And we have a liftoff technique
that finally provides us
with four contacts, two
of which are shown here.
But we actually put four
contacts on the sample.
And the resulting
picture is shown here.
The four contacts are
the-- this cross gives you
the four contacts and
their contact to big pads.
And then we can do experiments
related to the big pads.
But inside the middle of this
is the actual wire assembly.
That's shown here.
So here's our bismuth nanowire,
and here are the four contact
points.
So this allows us to do
voltage current measurements.
We are at the earliest
possible stages with this,
but we have our
first results showing
that the absolute
resistivity here--
so this current voltage
diagram, from the slope,
you can get the resistivity.
And the resistivity
is somewhat larger
than that of bulk
bismuth, a factor of 6,
showing a reduction in the
mobility of the carriers
due to boundary scattering
and probably other defects.
Now, we have a big
program ahead of us
to measure this all as a
function of temperature
and wire diameter.
So this will keep us
busy for many months.
I would like now
to say something
about how we go about
research in this field.
And this is kind of almost
getting to concluding remarks.
When we or any
other group starts
working in low-dimensional
devices and physics,
modeling becomes a very, very
important part of the exercise.
Without modeling,
we never can make
a device that will satisfy our
imagination for specifications
because in something
like thermoelectricity--
but it could be
almost anything else--
it's very easy to
make your device worse
than the
three-dimensional device.
And only by very
careful selection
of how to make the
design of the device will
you actually be
better than you are
in the three-dimensional system.
So I'd like to
emphasize the importance
of the concept of modeling
and then the use of modeling
to actually determine the
design parameters to get
a useful device.
So this is kind of a new
way of doing device design.
I know this is true in all
the other groups working
with nanostructures.
This is a different way
of looking at things.
And I'll just make
a couple of comments
about the situation
in bismuth, and then
I'll talk about some final
comments about doping
the samples and that we
think we know how to do it,
but it's a very
challenging thing
to do that for
bismuth nanowires.
When you start moving into
a new area and a new field
and the great unknowns,
there are many issues
that have not been previously
addressed by any investigator.
So you have to be careful
that you get it right.
Well the bismuth is
a complicated system
because we have holes.
Holes are pretty easy.
It's just a diagonal [INAUDIBLE]
for common semiconductors.
But the electrons are
much more complicated.
The constant energy surfaces,
there are three of them.
They're different
from each other,
and they're very
elongated ellipsoids,
not along high-symmetry
directions
but they're tilted from the
high-symmetry directions.
The other thing is that the
bandgap is so small that they
couple closely to each other.
So we cannot use the simple
parabolic model that we use
for holes, but we have to have
coupled band models so that
the calculation becomes
quite complex in a hurry.
So now, we have some remarkably
good students at MIT.
In concept, solving these
equations is straightforward.
The implementation is
not straightforward.
So Yumeng [? Lin ?] has just
finished his master's thesis
and figured out a very
nice numerical solution
for the Schrodinger
equation for the case
of anisotropic surfaces,
multiple carrier pockets,
and strongly coupled bands.
And it's based on this
grid structure which
allows us to do a
difference equation
and a numerical solution.
And the results have
been very interesting.
And this is the
first time we've been
able to get a quantitative
agreement with the experiments,
as I showed you before.
The next thing that has to
be done to make a device
is to control the doping,
both n and p-type.
The doping of n-type is
the one we started first
because that one is easier
in the case of bismuth.
The doping of p-type
is more complicated
for reasons I might explain.
And so first success
was obtained quickly.
So on the top, you
see pure bismuth.
And then the
connectivity increases
by a couple of orders of
magnitude when you dope it.
So you could see
that you could change
the properties by doping.
Bismuth is column five
of the periodic table.
Doping with an element in column
six gives you electrons n-type.
four should give you p-type.
And it sort of does
except for complications.
So we can dope our system.
And the next viewgraph
shows that we can change
the electrical properties.
So here's the
temperature dependence
of the normalized
resistance for different--
top picture, top
curve is for undoped.
And you see different
doping concentrations.
And you could see that
the resistance changes.
And from our model,
we can predict
what the effect of
carrier concentration is.
We know how much
dopant we've added.
We can imagine where
we are on this curve
and then from that back
out what the temperature
dependence of the mobility is.
And the results here turned
out to be far better than I
would ever have expected.
We have a model here for
the contribution from
electron-phonon interaction,
which is the undoped case,
from defects--
that's impurities that are
isoelectronic impurities that
are present or other defects--
and then charge scatterers.
And using just this simple model
and the different temperature
regimes, we're able to get
the correct temperature
dependence for each of
these phenomenon, each
of these processes.
And so this was
beyond my expectation.
I'm very proud of
Yumeng's result on this
because this was
better than I had
expected at our present
stage in this problem.
The problem of doing the
p-type doping, p-type doping,
is complicated by the
following physical phenomenon.
Doping with p-type is
very much controlled
by the p-type carriers that we
have in the intrinsic solid due
to these T-point holes.
And trying to lower
the Fermi level
by adding p-type
impurities is greatly
hampered by having this
large reservoir of holes.
And what we're hoping to do is
a new optimization approach--
this is work for the future--
is by adding a small
amount of antimony,
we hope to make some
kind of revolution
on the band
structure of bismuth.
We have a way of moving the
T-point holes, which are over
here, to lower energies,
and try to get them out
of the way of the carriers
that we would add by doping.
We figure that a few
percent of antimony
should be sufficient to
make a real difference
and to get some good p-type
dopant for device applications
where we need both n
and p-type materials.
Finally, this project
is somewhat driven--
we always have behind
us our masters who
are supporting this research.
And this is to try to make
a good thermoelectric.
The metal insulator
transition-- that
is the semimetal-semiconductor
transition--
occurs at about 40
to 50 nanometers.
That's a very, very big size.
There's interesting
science to be done there,
and we're working away
at that because that's
necessary to go
to the next step.
But our calculations
from our band models
show us that the interesting
device applications occur
at very much smaller sizes.
To get ZT-- that is the
thermoelectric figure
of merit--
to be greater than 1, we have
to have our n-type samples to be
on the order of 10 nanometers.
So that's a big challenge.
But even bigger challenge
is our p-type samples
have to be smaller than about
5 nanometers unless we're smart
and our idea with the
antimony doping works.
So we have a hard
master here that's
moving us to improve
our technology in making
and characterizing our samples,
and forcing us to understand
of our system in
great detail so we
can make some
realistic predictions
for this small size.
In the meantime, we're
spending quite a bit of effort
in trying to
understand the science
of the semimetal-semiconductor
transition
and in studying the properties
of this material, which
in nature doesn't occur
as a semiconductor,
but in low dimensions,
like nanowires, it does.
And it's a remarkable
new kind of semiconductor
that has very different features
from other semiconductors
in terms of the carrier pockets,
their orientations, the very
high mobilities that
are possible here,
ballistic transport, and
many other phenomena.
We're looking forward to having
some unusual optical properties
because of the close coupling
between the conduction
and valence band.
We expect high
dielectric constants.
And that might be
interesting for a whole band
of other applications
because there
aren't that many
semiconductors around with very
high dielectric constants.
So I will end my
talk at this point.
We started a new area,
and a lot of people
are looking at different
aspects of this in terms
of nanostructural science.
The fact that we have templates
has attracted a lot of people
into template use for putting
a lot of other materials
inside the pores, whether
they're magnetic materials
or superconductors
or what have you.
There are interesting
things to be
done with this new
category of materials,
and we continue also plugging
away at the thermoelectrics
because those are our
masters at the moment.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, do we have some questions?
Yes?
Have you observed
anything experimentally
that you think you don't
understand theoretically?
A lot of details are
not quite in place yet.
And I would say
that, for example, I
showed you the temperature
dependence of the resistivity.
We can't fit
everything in detail,
but we have the general
features blocked out now.
And we have to add--
well, for example, our
models are very crude.
We have a constant relaxation
time approximation.
We use that frequently
in doing our modeling.
That obviously is
not sufficient.
We should take into account
the actual scattering processes
for phonons.
There wasn't anything that seems
to be qualitatively peculiar.
Not down to the sizes that we
have studied up to this point.
I'm very interested-- there are
people at MIT that promise us
that they could make us some
smaller nanowires, smaller
than 4 nanometers in
diameter and smaller.
I believe at some point--
Who are they, by the way?
Wendy--
Oh, OK.
--has a method, and
I hope it works.
We don't know yet,
but that's one
of the virtues of being in
a large research university
with a lot of smart people.
You get help.
They listen to
what you're doing.
They have ideas
about some aspect
that interests them as well.
And I believe that there's
going to be some diameter where
we have a phase transition
and we don't have bismuth
as we know it.
It has a different crystal
structure from bulk bismuth.
And then we're going
to have nanowires
with some unknown properties,
maybe very interesting
but certainly different.
And we're looking
very hard to find out
what happens in that regime.
That's qualitatively different
from what we're doing now.
And we have no idea
where that will occur.
But we know down to 7
nanometers, it hasn't happened,
because we have measurements
of transport properties
down to 7 nanometers diameter.
And that still is
like bulk bismuth.
Now, bismuth has this
very long mean free path.
I mean, how long is that
it at, say, 77 [? K. ?]
It's millimeters long.
And why is that?
Why is it longer than, say, in a
modulation-doped semiconductor?
Why is it longer than in a--
Much longer, orders
of magnitude longer.
Like, say in a usual--
on a well, I mean, the mean
free paths are several microns,
a few microns.
OK, well, let me sort of
explain about bismuth.
And lead telluride has some
of the same properties.
If you have a material with a
very large dielectric constant,
the carriers are sort of
self-shielded by the fact
that you have a dielectric
constant of 100 or so.
And I think that that
is a large part of--
you have impurities present,
but the effect of the impurities
is greatly reduced
by screening effects
due to the high
dielectric constant.
That's one answer to it.
But of course, when
you have the quantum
wires that we have here, the
mean free path decreases.
It is--
Compared to the bulk, yeah.
Yeah, it's not larger than
the size of the nanowire.
Yeah, OK.
Any other questions?
Yes?
So I may have missed something,
your question earlier,
because the reason
for the semiconductor
is to get rid of the holes.
The reason for going for
a semiconductor is we
want a single carry.
[INAUDIBLE] cancel
each other, right?
Yeah, that's right.
You have a whole range
of phenomena where
electrons and holes cancels.
[INAUDIBLE] effect
is one of them.
Right.
The reason I was asking
[INAUDIBLE] even regardless
of what your doping
type is [INAUDIBLE]..
The bandgap can get quite large.
It can get more
than 100 millivolts.
[INAUDIBLE]
You could arrange the-- that's
what we're trying to do now,
is to arrange--
we would like to use
this as a 77 [? K. ?]
For device applications.
I think it fits bismuth
better than room temperature,
although I think we probably
can make a device higher
in temperature than 77.
But the first thing that we're
trying to do is 77 [? K ?]
because we know a lot about
the energy bands at 77 [? K. ?]
At higher temperatures,
they start
to get temperature-dependent.
And the data for the
dependents of all parameters
on temperature is very poor.
So we have a lot of
research to be done just
to find out what people normally
know about semiconductors.
And this-- yes, Caroline.
I know some people
who [INAUDIBLE]..
Yes.
What kind of difference is
in the physical structures of
[INAUDIBLE]?
OK, electrodeposition,
electrodeposition
is one of the things
that we hope to try.
Electrodeposition
has certain virtues
in that the wire at the
beginning and the end
is defined so that you can
make contact to all wires
that you have.
So that's a very big plus.
Up until now, there
has been some work
done on elctrodeposition
bismuth nanowires.
The problem is that the mean
free paths of those nanowires
is rather short and they can not
see ballistic transport the way
we do it with our nanowires.
That is, they have many,
many grains along the length
of a single nanowire.
We have relatively few grades.
We have some ideas
about how to make--
once we get a nanowire
in our template,
we have ideas how we can
make the grade size very much
larger.
So it's similar to what we have
in the pressure preparation.
This is only up here
with me and my students.
It's at the talking stage.
But I hope that
within a year or so,
we'll be able to demonstrate
some of these concepts.
The other thing about the
electrochemical method,
we hope to be able
to combine that
with orienting the nanowires
along desired directions.
So we could pick
the best direction,
which is the trigonal direction
for electrons and whatever
direction--
I've forgotten-- for the holes.
That will depend on the
dopant scheme that we use.
But that's the concept.
So we could use the substrate
to orient the wires.
But that's to be demonstrated.
I'm not sure we'll succeed.
Do I understand?
In this thermoelectric
application,
you'd have some sort of
an array of nanowires?
Yeah, yeah.
And you'd pass
current to them and--
Yeah, for thermoelectric,
if you're designing a wafer,
you have some integrated
circuit and you put this thing
underneath.
The geometry is what
they would like.
They don't really want
the geometry to be planar.
They like to have
the heat moving away
from the plane of the
integrated circuits.
So this is desirable.
And we can make these--
well, they could be--
I was thinking more of
replacing my refrigerator, but--
Oh, your refrigerator,
well, you'd
just have to have
a lot of these.
I see.
Question for you.
What's the Fermi
wavelength in these wires?
The Fermi wavelength
is pretty short
because your effective
masses are small.
Fermi surfaces are tiny compared
to the [INAUDIBLE] dimensions.
So your Fermi
wavelength is small.
If you compare it with
the wide diameter,
is it bigger or smaller?
You could arrange it
to be either way by--
I believe you could adjust the
design with your Fermi level
to be in either limit.
We haven't worked
on that problem yet,
but I believe you can do either
one, both for n and p-type,
for that matter.
So if it's greater
than the wide diameter,
the wire should be
one-dimensional.
And if it's smaller, it
should be three-dimensional.
Yeah well, we see those
kinds of transitions already.
Almost all the work up until
now on sort of classical size
effect have been on
three-dimensional limit.
And this work that we've
done is the first work
in the one-dimensional.
You need to have a small wire
to do the one-dimensional case.
OK, with no more
questions, I think
we should thank our speaker.
[APPLAUSE]